to
the
question time so i'm going to go through
questions here there's a lot of
questions i'm going to try and get
through
um
as much of them so
let me see
well you know carlos asks an interesting
question do you basically need all four
to have optimal setups
in the terms of i think he's referring
to
some of the other indicators no you
don't right
it's you know the way
i think one of the reasons why traders
fail so often
is
well there's a few reasons but but one
of them is
they get so focused on looking for one
thing in the markets right now i have
different indicators because you know
there's so many different market
conditions
okay there's not just one market
condition all the time sometimes the
market's trending sometimes it's range
bound right and sometimes you have
momentum picking up sometimes momentum
is drying out um you know each different
indicator
serves a different purpose okay and it
reads different things in the order flow
you know before
i started indicatoring
indicatorizing
different aspects of order flow
i was kind of like all over the place
right i would i had a core setup of
about four trade setups in the overflow
that i would look for
okay and then over time i started
developing
more
okay and at the end of the day
if you're focused on one market
you can do it it's easy if you're
experienced at it but
now
you know the the benefit that we have as
as
traders nowadays you know we're not on
the floor
we're our screen based traders everybody
is now
you're not limited to the markets you're
looking at right you could be looking at
crude oil e-mini's
mini russell
dao buns ultra bonds all right and not
just on 30-second charts for each of
them you know or you could be looking at
um you know e-mini's on a 30-second
chart you could be looking at a on a
2000 volume chart you could be looking
at a one-minute chart as well you know
you could actually be trading the same
market on sort of different
time frames or or chart types
so you know do you need all four
indicators you know flows driver shows
no you you don't all right but
you know i have people that have a lot
of these things um
i say
automated right and
you know they're using different
indicators
in their markets right some of them are
using um one indicator on on different
types of charts you know a 15 second
chart a 30 second chart um etc so
again you know it's about
it's about um finding what's
you know your sweet spots
anthony yeah i saw your email and get to
that a little bit later
um
yeah this is being recorded can you show
from 9 a um i'm not sure
uh which market edwards uh
carlos
you know carlos i i do offer training on
indicators i do a lot of i've posted a
lot of videos on the different
indicators over the time
um where is the point of entry on a
long or short signal
okay so
again the entry
the trade for example okay if you're
using the trade entry signal
what that's going to do is so you see
this bar here in the middle
right it's got the zone this is the
signal bar so
the low it's a red bar so i know it's
it's bearish
this will print the trade entry signal
print when we get two ticks away from
right so that would be uh 390. right as
soon as that prints that's when you get
short now again if you're using a tool
like
markers
from the indicator store
this one right you can
i use markers
uh
plus markers copy to
automate it right so i know that
as soon as it gets in right as soon as
it prints this
it executes the market order okay again
you have to automate that using a
third-party tool i i use markers
so i'm not necessarily worried about
that now again it will keep me
out of this trade
now if i'm not using the trade entry
signal
there would be a
blue triangle here giving me an entry
signal and if i were just to execute off
that
manually or even automated
it's going to stop me out right but
if i was you know if i'm looking at a
market that's slower for example
um
let me change this to uh buns
there's buttons here
okay because you know buns is a market
that moves
slower and
problem is you can't use a
30 second chart on buns for this you
know even a minute base chart is going
to be a little bit tricky
but
uh what settings i got on this one i
forgot already this is my euro currency
is the five so it's the pure setting
right so
if i were to
turn off the
trade entry signal so what do i got
there's a two minute chart trading entry
signal right it's just giving me the
signal not i said you know slower
markets like buns or
ultra bonds you know there's a market
that i'm able to follow a little bit
more closely so how i would trade it
right
okay i got my short signal here right i
know the low is coming in here i have
time to manually drop in a cell stop
below the low here right one i can just
get in but i like to let the market
confirm to me
sooner rather than later it's moving in
that direction right i know i got a
double bottom here i'm selling into this
double bottom
but if i'm getting that follow through
order flow
you know i want to be taking that trade
right just as
you know up here
okay so i know this this is the signal
bar i've got the triangle
on the signal
but again all i got to do is i just drop
in my cell stop right here a couple
ticks below the low of this bar
now if i'm using
excuse me the trade entry signal
all it does is it shifts over
the signal to the next bar and will
print as soon as it moves
two ticks below the low of the signal
bar right over the next two bars
so for example
yesterday was anything
or this is
this morning i think
here was your signal bar right trade
entry signal
okay so the low is
61.
next bar 61 next bar 60 was until the
third bar they traded 59 right so
if you were
that's why there's no signal there right
there's no red triangle because it
didn't move two ticks in the next two
bars
if i
were to change this you know
tradeability bars from two
to three
right now you're seeing it there right
or if i disable it
it will
give me the signal right on
the signal bar all right so enough that
that helps you uh
let's see can i see it yes 10 minutes
well
yeah i can show you a 10 minute chart um
but again
after 10 minutes you're you're really
you're really discounting the value of
the order flow that you saw
even five minutes prior
okay
it's you know honestly i think it's
there's other ways to use order flow on
a 10-minute chart
rather than
this tool um
there's other things on a
that
other parts of order flow that i think
are more conducive to
a longer term
and i hate to call 10 minutes a longer
term chart but
you know a chart that's got a longer
duration because again you know you're
really trying to take advantage of what
you're seeing in the order flow
happening
right now
so
anyway
going to take a while for that chart to
come up rbs have you looked at time of
day for whether the signals are better
or
worse well
it's you know i don't like to say oh you
can't trade the night session or you
can't trade
um you know the
the evening session i did find
you know i do find that
with a lot of markets
you sort of keep
when they
when volume starts
slowing down okay for like crude for
bonds
you know after
two o'clock chicago time even for gold i
mean there's still moves like today
right we had that nice late move in gold
um but a lot of times those things sort
of come out of the blue now
i i
obviously the us session is is the most
active session but the european session
you know is is active in a lot of
markets right
certain markets
trade a lot during the asian session you
know aussie dollar trades a lot
obviously during the aussie hours
japanese yen um
even gold right has is very active
during
the
asian sessions you know asia is a big
gold trading center right and there's
big moves to be had
um in those markets right and and
obviously
london is is a good time to be trading
many markets so it's
you know i i don't like to necessarily
close it off
you know certain times of the day
um
you know the
the illiquid times the person i find a
lot of markets
we'll slow down you know i'm in chicago
area
you know the 11 until one o'clock time
11 pm until 1am you know 1am is when
um
you know traders in europe start coming
in because that's like what 7 eight in
the morning there that's when things
start to pick up again because you know
honestly some a lot sometimes it's like
watching paint dry you know trading that
that uh
11 p.m until
1 a.m but there's other markets to trade
all right you don't have to necessarily
trade
every single market um you know on that
time you know what you'd want to do
you know you'd buy your bonds right if
you're trading during european hours
trade buns right if you're trading
um
asian hours
you know you go to japan you go to
um
nikai
on
cymex right you get quotes for that it
it moves
you know it's got good movements um this
is
you know it does break for lunch but you
know there's there's good movements to
be had in these markets right but you
got to understand the market that you're
trading
i don't know if that answers your
question but um
and we looked at time and day you know
honestly it's just one of those things
where it really depends on on what time
specifically
you're looking for right this is
nikai five
um you know on well it's a two minute
chart you know
you can trade one minute uh very easy
uh
vetomas do you have any suggestions on
how to automate these signals and also
the back this yeah i use
markers
from the indicator store
pablo um
you know we got a lot of
we've had some collaboration in the past
and
you know that's that's what i use you
know i don't get paid for promoting
markers or anything like that it's i i
recommend it because
that's what i have
okay now bloodhound i have some users
that are very adept at bloodhound and
they tell me they've been able to use my
indicators in bloodhound for testing
purposes
but i don't use bloodhound
um just pull back
they'll spill back could be target
signals and not reverse trade signals
um
yeah okay because you got another
question about es so let me find
um where's my es chart so where was that
that was go back to the 10 minute chart
so this is a 10 minute chart you know
are there signals yeah
you know you sort of want to find your
sweet spot in terms of settings
but again it's
one of those things where
you know this is the very minimum based
setting here right one
right so you know again you're
it's one of those do you want to
use a 10-minute chart because there's
again things that happen early
you want to take advantage of it as as
quickly as possible i mean that's that's
just me
um
all right so i'll show you so this is
ees he wants to see
um
anyway just really quick right
before i get into that dale um
one of the ways that i use these
zones right and again i don't recommend
this for everybody but people ask me
mike why do you draw the zone out five
price levels right because
generally i know if trade is not working
out for me within five price levels it's
going to fail
period you know i don't want to be in
that trade i don't want to be spinning
around you know
back and forth around break even
and sort of caught up you know we all
get caught up sometimes we feel like
we're
you know it's like
bad trade is like a bad relationship
right you want to get out of it but
you're afraid to get out of it right no
no one's going to love me again but
why i use these why i have these zones
drawn out five price levels
for five bars rather all right you see
one two three four five
generally the way i
use it sometimes
i don't program it into
markers or anything like that but if i'm
trading
manually and i see the market is like if
that market's been selling off right and
okay i gotta buy yeah it's moving in my
direction and if it fails right if the
market is trending right it's not a
market i'm talking about going sideways
all right market has to be trending
right here we sold off from
what is that around the 85 level
down to 60 more or less okay i got a buy
signal great you know we just sold off
20 points
25 points i got something bullish coming
in that's great but if i get bullish
and i buy
and it just fails immediately like
within those five bars
and i could see that well you know we
just sold off 20 points
maybe there's more to this move
right and i'm willing to get short if it
breaks that within five points or five
the zone basically five bars right which
it did on the fourth bar obviously the
fifth bar is still below it right that's
to me is a sign
that
uh don't fight the trend right i could
go
i can still go in that direction um and
be okay
again i don't recommend that for
everybody you have to have your
fit into your trading plan um control es
with the strongest filters compared to
medium strength yeah sure that's uh
see if i could change this chart here to
e-mini's
remove these two
i'll change this to
yes
and
move this one
add another
come on there we go
yes but i don't want
50 volume
i'll just keep it simple second 30
seconds for both of these
30 seconds
now you have to use tick replay for this
uh some people i don't like tick replay
well i'm sorry but you got to use it uh
panel this will be panel one i'll make
this one a new panel
okay
ions let's see
e-minis
well
we'll just use the
uh where are we here flows bounce
disable that i'll keep this one as you
know the strongest
the pure sense
zero five zero uh uh same as input
series
okay
then i'll add the other one on here
whoops one
and this one i'll change to
the weakest or
keep it at mid
medium strength you know i don't know
for this purpose i'll keep it at three
and
today
same as input series no i want it in
panel two
okay
so let's see here give it a second
sometimes you know adding these things
it takes those
on two charts on one um there he asked
how do triangles print when the bar
closes
if you're using the trade
entry signal
okay
there's two different ways to use it
okay one is
if you're not using the trade entry
signal as soon as the conditions in the
bar meet it will print
okay
and if conditions change it'll disappear
and conditions reappear it'll print
again but once the bar closes that's it
right it won't appear or disappear
anymore if the
you're using the trade entry signal
as soon as it appears on the next bar or
two
that's it right it'll
that's telling you conditions are met in
the order flow in the follow-through
order flow
take the trade period okay
and it won't reprint if conditions
change because conditions were already
set in the signal bar and the
follow-through order in the next bar or
two
appeared and now the signal is printing
but again if you're using the trade if
you're not using the trade entry signal
if you're just
trading for the actual signals
then
um the base depending on on your trading
plan
then you're going to take the trade
either immediately or you can wait for
the bar to close and the signal to
either be there or not be there okay so
i hate to say it's confusing but you
know that's why i put the trade entry
signal in there
um years ago on started putting them in
on all my tools because that's how i was
trading so for example
okay so here's sort of getting back to
the previous question
okay here's the top that's the e-mini's
bottom e-mini 30-second chart so
this is the pure setting right the
strong signal
this is
the setting at three which is kind of a
mid
uh mid setting so i don't know if you
can see in here
okay for example
there's the cell signal right down here
on the bottom chart and then there's
a blue zone drawn out but there's no
blue triangle right like here you have
the blue triangle followed by the red
triangle so conditions were met
here
in this bar
before the red triangle was met up here
when we're trading at the swing high up
here
that's why you got the signal here right
and then you got the sell signal the
market sold off
you got the sell signal here conditions
were forming
for a buy signal now if i was not using
the trade entry signal there would be a
blue triangle here right and i would
have gotten out of this short but
conditions were met but there wasn't
that follow through bullish order flow
that's why there's no signal there and
you can see the market
sold off again
okay
so
up here is the strong setting down here
sort of is the medium setting it's not
the weakest setting
but it's a it's a medium setting it's
set to three so you can see in here
right there is a buy signal down here
catch this move up
over here you have the two signals side
you know
both of them appeared
but on the stronger setting you don't
have the buy that happened lower
right so this is
a medium setting right if i were to add
um
you know
setting it weaker like you see stopped
out here stopped out here
could have got this one would not have
stopped you out because it stayed below
yeah that's what i use that's what i'm
talking about using the zones
as my stop as my stop level because i
know that if i you know
this bar is bearish okay
and i get the follow-through order flow
right coming in at 46
top of this bar is 46 and three quarters
right
my stops up here at 47 just behind it
you know it could be one tick above
two ticks above
i'm risking
i'm getting short it you know 46 was
that 46 45 and three quarters i stopped
up here at 47.
all right and then it comes down here
it's trading 44 and a half i get a
bullish signal
okay
i'm short from you know 46 okay i could
cover it right here now i catch that
move back up
okay this one obviously would have
stopped you out here
right and again you know what i was
talking about you know five
five price levels right if it comes back
up within
five levels right like
here down if you could see it i should
try and move this chart up a little bit
here
but uh well let me just go back over
um
it's my e-mini 32nd by big chart here
if
uh
if i got it
well what's the settings on this one
just like
be consistent on the settings
five well i set it at um
three
just to sort of you know be consistent
because what time was that uh 11
10 50.
okay
madam asks about uh
scaling in well
now that there's the the micro contracts
this is great for scaling in for a lot
of traders because you know if you're
just trading one lot you know one lot of
the
e-minis you can't scale in unless you're
trading more
but rather than trading one lot of the
e-normally minis if you're using micros
you can start to scale in of course you
know you want to use a regular broker
um that's not charging you five dollars
or something for
the trade
but um
you can do that right now with with the
micros right and obviously
um
you have that ability to do that
christopher asked about range based
charts does it work on range based
charts well it it does i don't
use range based charts so much anymore
but i'll show you in a second but this
was talking about right the zone is
being drawn out so if i'm short here
right i got the signal all right then it
comes right back up against me
all right i can get long here
all right
but again it's not for everybody right
if i get long up here comes down here
right if i get short off this failed buy
signal it just sort of spins around
before it goes back up so again it's not
for everybody it's not you know i don't
want to start telling people to stop and
reverse on trades
you have to sort of work it into your
your style of trading okay
and again i i i would be taking it after
certain types of price movements in the
market but again that would be another
um
another conversation for another another
time
can you use range based charts well of
course you can so here let's just
put on a range based chart
really quick
this is calculating steve um
i didn't see your email i'll have to
check my spam folder sometimes my emails
go to spam
but i'll check it steve
is this indicator only available for
ninjatrader 8 yes it is
it's not available for sierra charts
and
i don't know
when my indicators will be available on
sierra charts because you know right now
i use ninjatrader
um
you know
part of the problem with sierra charts
is finding a programmer i'm not a
programmer
and my programmer for ninjatrader is
brilliant he knows exactly
what i want to do
and how i want to do it
that is very easy for me now i could i
could tell him you know and give him the
framework and he can go down and he does
it and i don't really need to make many
changes because we've been working
together for six or seven years
um but with sierra charts a lot you know
it's hard to find a programmer that
understands order flow
okay and the ones that do
um
you know i just have bad experiences
with uh some programmers
on sierra charts that's all but um you
know i got to find someone that i trust
and is going to do it correctly now this
is a range based chart okay so
again the setting
is set to three you know if i were to
set it to five i'd probably want to use
um
you know i don't know the enhanced
lookback filter maybe set a minimum
difference level of two i don't know how
that's going to look but the problem
with
sometimes with with
range based charts is
a market can pick up ahead of steam and
move very far
very quickly right because it's just
it's based on price movements so you
know you could be looking at
you could be putting in three or four
bars
and by the time you get in the markets
moves already happened
right especially if you're trading
certain markets like uh
nasdaq or something you know unless
you're trading like 25 range bar
um they're able to take into account a
lot of stuff
then
you know you can do that
so again this is a
eight range chart you know you can sort
of see the signals
coming in here you know i've set some
filters
on where's my cursor you know you catch
some moves up some moves down you get
stopped out here catch the move down
stopped out catch a little move down a
little sideways activity
you know back and forth i don't know um
depends on the type of range based chart
you're using you know you could if
you're
you know i don't know who would use a 15
range chart
on
e-minis but you know
people do you know i'm never surprised
you know sometimes i get emails from
people saying this is the type of chart
i'm looking at and first i'd scratch my
head and say why but um you know if it
works for you it works for you you know
who am i to tell you to do something
different if you're
comfortable and you're successful you
know training a certain chart type you
don't necessarily have to change that
right but what i'm saying is add a tool
to it
all right so
yes you have to put tick replay on for
flows bounce
um okay i just showed you an eight range
chart
yes only for a ninja trader
how's it different from the pulse
it's
completely different
pulse measures momentum
in the markets
and
power bars
starts to delve into a bit into order
flow okay but um
this one deals more with
order flow and volume profile
uh sorry the power button
starts to delve a bit into volume
profile but this one's more focused on
volume profile together with order flow
so there's a 15 range chart right
because now e-mini's or
you know train nicely you know
you only need to catch one trade today
right boom it's up
now you know sometimes that's why i said
i'm never amazed never shocked now
on the type of range-based charts people
use
right again you know this was
this was yesterday
fed day you know there's there's some
moves to be had
on a 15 range chart on on a i
would not use a four range chart on the
e-minis anymore it just it just moves
too quickly
for this particular indicator there's
other tools i would use for shorter
range chart
um
[Music]
can you show e-mini's on european open
yeah sure
i said you know the european session
is active right there's
there's good participation
during the european session um
in the e-minis the amount of volume that
trades in the e-minis during the
european session is
better than some markets trade during
the us normal hours so it's it's a good
um
it's a perfectly fine
time of day to be trading
um carlos you have to send me an email
um carlos
yeah
jared asked about where would you be
placing your stop
well i've always believed in placing
your stop
you know behind a level that the
market's gotta
sort of
work to get through right so if i have a
signal bar
you know if i have orderful autonomy one
thing
that's bullish or bearish so for example
tell me something that's bullish and the
market starts going up
if it gets through that bearish order
flow then that's my sign to be getting
out of the trade um now of course you
know when you use something like um you
know any sort of
trade
you know atm or whatever you really have
to put in
you know a level you know like 10 ticks
15 ticks whatever but
i just simply
adjust it right because you know the atm
will just go in and throw it in there
for you
and then i just manually adjust it
right there's no there's a law that says
you can't adjust your
your order once it goes in all right so
let's see this is the
european open here
see what uh
it says calculating so it's it's sort of
going through that
that part um
james i i don't use wrinkle charts and i
i don't like the renko charts the native
ninjatrader wrinkle charts
um
that are on ninjatrader
i just don't find them very useful all
right so this is well this is the
european open
today with the pure setting there was no
signals there until later right
now
one of the problems and i'll say
problems one of the
things you have to keep in mind right
with trading
order flow is
these bars are not there's not enough
going through at this time all right
that's why there's no signals right
you're only talking a bar that's 43.95
and a quarter 95 and a half so two ticks
right
it doesn't start analyzing the order
flow until there's at least
price movement right if you're getting
bars that are two ticks there's not
going to be anything it's not going to
give you
any signals and it's programmed that way
right there has to be some movements in
the bar
so this is the the strict setting or the
pure setting
but you know the day before
right now you're seeing some price
activity
right there's a cell here
i'll buy in a cell
a buy here this caught this move down
that's the european open go back the day
before
the european open
uh what was this one o'clock here
it's alibi here but again that's the
strict setting you know under different
situations again
you can adjust it to a more of a mild
setting a three
or even
two
the three i'd sort of consider
i mean
there's no two and a half settings got
to be one two or three
four or five
um
but if you know anywhere between two and
three would sort of be the midpoints you
know depending on
on what
your
your view is but um
if two would be a little bit weaker
three be a little bit stronger
but um
you know again going back to james
question there's
many different renko charts out there um
so
it's i don't know which one is is better
but you know uni renko some people have
sent me their uni wrinkle charts and
they look nice but again it depends on
who it comes from so like this is a
setting of three
right so you see there's there's more
signals right now you can catch have
caught this move yeah you get a little
back and forth action here you get
stopped out fine then you get the signal
then you catch this this move up to
somewhere up in here hopefully from 75
76 up to 82
you know
there's moves to be had during that time
um flows what's the difference between
order flow 3.0 versus flow bounces is a
big difference 3.0 is the footprint
chart flows bounce is not a footprint
chart close bounce just analyzes order
flow in one aspect the footprint chart
is this
doesn't have flows bounce in it
but it's got all you know it's the
footprint chart basically in the volume
profile chart um we got all the delta
information volume profile
um
value areas of the bars prominent points
controls imbalances et cetera et cetera
it's completely different product
and it's
when you buy flows bounce you don't get
the order flows 3.0 trader
what about creating a strategy for using
these indicators
yeah you know if you're using a tool to
do it you can do that you know i said i
use
markers
uh uh what about
let's see here raymond can any markers
plus let you stop loss of the zone well
you'd have to adjust it
um
does it work on stocks
yeah i don't it does work on stocks i
don't use i don't trade stocks i don't
use stocks i don't trade stocks but
again you know when you're trading
stocks
um
i don't know
it's
it's i don't know um
how to say
yeah i'm a i'm a futures guy all right
i'm from chicago i grew up in chicago
area worked on the exchange floor
um i'm not in new york i was born in new
york i am not a
new york person so to speak but
do i even have data for stocks
i'll see if anything comes up but yeah i
mean you can
use it on stocks um
what is this can you show latest turn
signals versus flow balance on one
minute 20 range nq chart
okay so here's apple hey
yeah sure i'll i'll drop it in q chart
uh
full spots
um
well i'll use a look back filter
and
yeah i don't know i'll just keep it at
one and one i'll use a look back filter
a five again i'm curious the thing is
with stocks
you
personally i find if you're going to
look at stocks with order flow you want
to be
you know sticking to the more
um active stocks
do you want any key this is mnq uh what
is that here just change it here real
quick
yeah i use apple
and this is just a one minute chart
you know so there's signals you know
there depends on how you trade stocks
again it's
this is a one minute chart you know you
could look at a five minute chart you
could do a lot of different things um
yeah you could use one minute charts i
just show the charts that
i like to use
um
[Music]
steve okay i'll check edit
i'll check your email
i'm in california
i hope it's been nitrate for an hour
it's worth it yeah
nikai nikai's is a great
chris block brock chris sent me an email
um you should have got the
update emails
um
for 2.0 to 3.0
uh we set those out like a year ago but
uh you know sometimes people are
busy doing you know their lives um so
this is a 20 range chart again
this is the
you know set the three i'll set it to
five i use a minimum difference level
um
you know
i don't know two
it's it's a bit wider chart right so
it's arrangements of 15 oh sorry it's a
20 range chart
so
you know there's price movements
uh
that's occurring in here
okay i mean i should throw another
look back
well
the thing is if using the enhanced look
back
you don't necessarily need to use the
swing filter as well you can
but um
you know for now just disable it
okay yeah so anyway let's see
how it looks
uh
well there's this big flow's bounce
again it's
pulse turns power bars
they're all different parts of the order
flow that's being read all right
and
again turns looks for more market
generated support or resistance um
turns looks for
market generated momentum
and power bars
i i've got something coming out
the complement power bars honestly it's
it's still in development and going back
and forth with the program because i use
a different programmer for power bars um
because power bars you know sort of the
first indicator that that's more into
understanding value
in the market you know power bars deals
with
value the market moving through value so
this is a 20 range chart
on the e-mini sorry on nq but again you
know
it's not a chart that i normally look at
so
i'm not
familiar with sort of the price
um
activity right and you know the reason i
say that i'm not trying to shy away from
anything but the reason i say that is
because you know when you're looking at
markets right you have to understand
your markets do you want to have a
strong setting or a weak setting you
know is it type is a
if you're using especially a range based
chart is it moving very quickly or not
right because i could look at a four
range chart in
wheat that moves
quicker than a four-range chart in five
years all right so
you there's there's different things you
gotta understand because that's going to
adjust how you use
um the settings there
uh okay so last question here from phil
what's your thought on optimization and
ninjatrader
well
it's one of those things yeah you don't
want to over optimize something right to
the point of curve fitting
and
except that's not going to do you any
good going forward yet in the bat in the
past that's great you know but you're
not going to be trading in the past you
sort of want to have a set of
parameters that you can work around
rather than having something you know
exactly you know because yeah it's one
of these things you know sometimes i see
people oh you know i use a 38
bar moving average well
okay
why you just use a 40 well no no 38 is
the best well it's because they tested
every single one and found out you know
it's one percent better but that's just
based on historical data right i said
the historical data is completely
different than what you're looking at
now right what even the order flow i
could show you charts from five years
ago the way the market is trading now
even though you know order flow is still
roughly the same
volume is greater
right and that's going to
change sort of different things that
you're looking at
right you gotta because you know
when obama was president
yeah i would trade you know e-mini's you
know 10 sometimes the 10-handle range
in the e-minis you know overnight was
very big
all right sometimes you have five-point
ranges in the e-minis overnight
in 2016 2015.
trump came into office
you're having 20 point ranges overnight
right so you know the markets
change right and
yes so if i
go back and and you know
look for you know certain types of
activity from a year ago two years ago
what i'm looking at now is
you know slightly different so when you
talk about optimization right you don't
want to optimize yourself out of
a good trading plan you know because
people say ah you know discard this
discard that discard that where you know
sometimes
you know it it's not here you
if you're searching for perfection
you'll never find it
right you know and
again i'm going to diverge here really
quick but there's you know
as
you know
my
wife belongs to some of these online
groups
you know people selling stuff online
and there's a woman complaining
she's got a great customer keeps buying
her stuff but she never leaves five-star
reviews showing these four-star reviews
and she's i can't handle this you know
this person keeps buying my stuff and
but she only gave me four stars instead
of five stars and so now she wants to
get rid of that customer
even though the customer's very happy
but the woman that's selling it's like
no i want perfection i want five stars
or i don't want you know it's like why
you know you got a perfectly good
customer that's buying your stuff and
you know on a regular basis but just
because you're not leaving your
five-star review you know that that's
you know searching for perfection
is is killer you know that that's a
strange example but um you know when
you're dealing with optimization
you know sometimes people try to look
for perfection that they discard things
that are not uh
yeah you know it's like false hope right
you discard something that that's
perfectly fine
but you know instead of finding
something that's giving you 100 returns
you find something that's only giving
you
58 returns well the 58 returns is still
good
right and you know you don't want to
sort of knock yourself out of that
that arena by oh discarding it i i
didn't find you know it's not optimized
the way i like and again you know it
sort of goes into the whole curve
fitting thing which is not really a good
way to go right you want to have a set
set
of parameters that you could apply
that that will work
honestly it's not going to work every
single time there's nothing works every
single time but it works often enough
right that that you're consistent right
because that's what there's no holy
grail in trading the holy grail and
trading is really consistency in trading
it's not about optimizing everything all
right guys anyway i don't keep you guys
on too long at six o'clock oh my gosh
we've been on for two hours
so again you know if
if you're interested in it you guys all
got the emails
but just go to
flowsbounce.com to get started right
that's that's the
that's the link
and
you know i
am
hoping
to get a i got to talk to pablo maybe we
can do
something together but i'm probably
going to create a video because a few
people have asked me about automating it
with markers um in case you want to you
know know how to go about automating it
and hopefully this weekend i'm probably
going to get another video out i'll just
record it i'm not going to do a live
session on flows bounce as well
um it'll be up on youtube and i'll be
sending you guys you know an email on it
yeah just sort of showing you more
because you know honestly uh the today's
session went two hours which is kind of
long um for a lot of people there's
still like 90 guys on here which is
great but you know i really
think this is a terrific tool that can
help a lot of people and you know i want
to show you more ways that you can use
it et cetera et cetera to get the most
out of it so thanks everybody
and again have a great night and
you know get started just go to
flowsbounce.com and i'll see you guys
oops sorry on the inside bye-bye
you